The thing about it,
man,
I talked about my book open mindedness,
which separates me from a lot of people is they go into in a daunting task in
the task is overwhelming.
Like when I heard the pullup Breck was 4,020 pull ups and I was talking about
breaking this record.
People are like,
oh my God,
I went right to a pen and paper.
Then what are you doing?
I'm doing the math man.
We Tom,
but I'm open minded to the fact that okay,
if I do five pull ups in a minute for so many hours I can get some many pull ups
in how much time they had the rest.
I was breaking the math down yet be open minded to the possibilities that I can
do this.
Once you shut your mind down to the possibility that it can be a cheese is no
way can happen.
So that's why my my eyes and my body light up about things because I know that
if you're in a fight you have to attack,
you have to keep attacking.
The enemy has to know he is not going to give up.
You must break the soul or whatever the fuck is in front of you.
That's what I realized.
I was never breaking the soul,
anything in front of me,
so that's why I came with a thing called taking soles.
In my book,
I started to devise ways to break a soul of a human being of a,
of an object of,
of,
of whatever's in front of me.
If he keep on attacking something,
nothing wants to stand in front of anything that is relentless.
Nothing.
The taking sole part of the book is really interesting because a,
you talked about like the,
the mind shift that you had when you were in bud's.
Yes sir.
That was it.
That's an intense part of the book.
It is a,
that's when a lot of stuff started clicking man.
I started watching those instructors on the side.
Could,
you know there's,
there's three shifts.
There's eight instructors,
three shifts,
cause you know the guy's going to do hell week.
They're up all day and all night for her 30 hours.
This is the promised land of mental hardening for me.
I love this place.
And you had the instructors who,
who,
you know,
they've been there,
done that.
Now they're instructing you.
So they do the eight hour shift they had,
their park is on,
it's usually cold coffee drinking their coffee and they're beating the crap out
of us.
And when I started realize I started playing mind games and I was like,
you know what?
I bet these fuckers are looking at us judging themselves about when they were
going through hell week about,
let me see,
I'm looking at Goggins right now.
I was buried in him.
I was bearing that cost burden,
that fucker over there.
And I was like,
okay,
you're gonna Judge me,
right?
So I'm will do to you.
So when I started doing was I got my boat crew,
boat crew too.
It's in the book is a great,
great story.
Said Kimra guys,
you can't break boat crew that you can't break broke crew too.
So we as winter day is Wednesday and everybody's broken.
Everybody's beat up man.
And like this.
I mean you start moving like a robot.
Everybody's like just kind of just trying to get to hell week now and your
energy zap and they know where's days like that over the hump.
I love that you talked about that in the book too,
that they put it in your head.
We Wednesday you're going to be tight and that's nothing.
They,
they tell you how you're supposed to feel.
So you are feeling that way.
I was like,
ah,
don't let these motherfuckers tell you how you're supposed to feel.
No,
it's day one motherfucker.
This is our one.
So I was getting my book are all jacked up.
I said we could take these motherfuckers souls.
So when they had us doing this simple thing that gods are struggling with broke
grew too.
Was this launched in the fucking bone?
You're yelling.
Yeah,
he can't fucking hurt us.
Get hurt.
Boat crew too.
And I looked on the instructor's faces and it looked like someone had just
fucked with their soul.
And I looked at my garden,
my broker,
and I said,
hey,
guess what?
Those mother fuckers aren't fucking tonight.
Can we own space in their fucking head?
We own space.
They're gonna think about us tonight.
They could think about how they callin boners.
That's right.
Charging and we start fueling off of that which are few fuel,
not the fact that man,
it takes one second of energy to still everybody's and then you have all the
energy you need.
It's all you need.
You need to look at someone's eyes.
You know how it is when you fight somebody and you broke that motherfucker.
He's like,
Oh God,
man,
I don't want to go back to the next round and you feel like,
my God,
I can fight all day.
I can fight all day long.
That's what taking Solos is,
but you have to have the will to heart the courage to go that distance when
you're exactly jacked up.
We have nothing left to give and give more.
That is an interesting thing about the mind is that you can find inspiration and
when you find inspiration,
when you get charged up,
all the sudden you have energy.
That's right.
It's right.
It's weird.
I talked about in the book also is about I learned how to control my adrenals.
If you know how you know how you get that fight or flight response when you get
to move real quick.
And you know,
I started learning the mind a lot,
how to get myself jacked extremely fast,
like in a horrible environment when everybody's miserable.
I learned how to really find strength in the misery when everybody's suffering.
Everybody's all poopy pants and their mentalities down and everything.
I started just like my God,
this is where I shine it.
I started using all that misery for tons and tons of tons of drive and
motivation to to then lead people further.
Cause you can get a lot of power through misery.
And once people see that,
my God Goggins is fucking going,
then everybody says Roger that let me get my shit and go to.
So I started realizing that if you can just find strength just a little bit
longer,
you will have a crew of people following you along the way.
That is another thing that no one can ever teach you does you.
You're going to have to learn that on your own.
You're going to have to figure out how to pull that energy out of your mind on
your own.
Does not this,
there's no book.
You can read the,
all of a sudden I have it.
I've got the technique now know how to do it.
Yeah.
Now it's,
it's a grind that you have to start and finish on your own.
You have to take great pleasure in the fact that no one wants to be with a fuck
you're at right now.
Great pleasure in that.
Most makes,
you know,
it has to bring a passion.
Nadia has to bring something very,
very weird audio man.
Like you know,
people don't really understand what that is.
When you're in the worst environment possible,
the worst situation possible,
and everybody looking like,
God,
man,
I hope this ends.
And you see that time slows down and you see that you're,
you're feeling that everybody has that look on their face like,
God,
it's got to go.
I don't want to be anymore.